Dans l'Amazonie française,
Le stage forêt entre dans sa dernière semaine.
Et sa partie la plus redoutée,
La survie.
Les hommes sont désormais livrés à eux mêmes.
Ça, c'est des feuilles de Toulouri.
On va confectionner un abri avec ça,
Pour se protéger de la pluie et des insectes qui tombent la nuit.
Avec un équipement réduit au strict minimum,
Les soldats ne peuvent maintenant compter que sur eux mêmes.
Sam prépare son bivouac à l'aide de sa seule machette.
C'est pour en faire une fourche, pour faire mon abri personnel.
Et après, il va falloir que j'en récupère une deuxième.
Là c'est de la survie.
Emilio n'est pas mieux outillé.
On a rien ramené, parce que c'était la surprise.
J'ai que mon coupe-coupe, c'est tout.
Après trois semaines d'instruction,
Les militaires passent de la théorie à la pratique.
Ont-ils assimilé les rudiments de la survie en forêt ?
Chacun y va de sa technique.
Le légionnaire Nikolaï a presque terminé sa tanière.
Là, c'est mon petit lit.
J'ai utilisé les tranches de Toulouri.
Je les ai attaché avec une petite liane.
Moi, ça me plaît, ma petite maison de fortune.
Je vais bien dormir ce soir ici !
Première mission réussie pour Nikolaï.
Il peut se concentrer à présent sur la nourriture.
À cette heure avancée de la journée,
Pas le temps de chasser, ni de pêcher.
Il faut se rabattre sur l'essentiel,
Ce que la nature a de plus simple à offrir.
Dans les palmiers on peut en manger le cœur.
Il est tout en haut.
Il faut qu'on l'ouvre.
Les brésiliens utilisent ça pour leurs salades.
Beaucoup d'efforts fournis,
Pour au final,
N'obtenir qu'une minuscule tranche de palmiers aux goûts peu agréables.
Il n'est pas très bon.
Normalement c'est ça, mais il doit être meilleur.
D'autres en sont encore à préparer leur abri,
Comme le légionnaire Eliaquim.
Je suis en train de préparer mon lit de fortune.
Je suis un peu en retard, mais je vais y arriver.
Eliaquim perd beaucoup de temps avec son projet très ambitieux.
J'ai déjà mes matelas qui sont là.
Que je vais coupé en 2 par la suite.
Puis je vais transposé comme ceci.
Ça ressemblera à un brancard.
Mais au moins on ne dort pas par terre, c'est toujours mieux,
On évite les scorpions, on évite les insectes.
De son côté, remis de sa blessure à la main,
Pierre s'attaque à un autre impératif imposé par les instructeurs,
Le feu.
En sachant que le taux d'humidité en Guyane dépasse les 80%,
Et qu'il vient juste de pleuvoir avant qu'on y arrive.
C'est très, très compliqué.
C'est de la patience. C'est un peu comme à la pêche.
1h d'efforts pour y arriver, Pierre peut enfin souffler.
Que demander de plus ?
Dans ce contexte, c'est royal.
Là je suis au Saint-Georges, je suis au Plazza !
Mais très vite,
Il est appelé par Sam.
Avec ce singe dans les parages,
Les deux hommes ont peut être trouvé de quoi se nourrir.
Ils se mettent en chasse.
Ici, le singe n'est pas une espèce protégée.
Raté,
La première tentative ne sera pas la bonne.
Tout se mange dans la selva.
Tout se mange dans la jungle.
Sauf justement les singes, interdits par les instructeurs.
Comme c'est vecteur de beaucoup de maladies,
Ils préfèrent ne pas prendre de risques,
Mais ils nous filent le poids du singe en riz.
Donc là, il doit faire 1,5 kg.
On va avoir 800 grammes de riz.
Vaut mieux un bon 800 grammes, qu'un mauvais rien du tout.
Du riz qu'ils ne récupéreront que le lendemain.
En attendant, chacun doit se procurer sa propre nourriture.
Pour Pierre, ce sera un repas très léger.
Du bon cœur de palmier, du fruit.
Là dedans, il y a juste de l'eau.
Ça me fera de la flotte.
Pierre se contentera de l'eau contenue dans les fruits.
Pour d'autres, c'est la corvée.
100 mètres à parcourir dans la nuit pour trouver la première rivière.
L'eau est boueuse, mais Evgin ne fait pas la fine bouche.
Elle est bonne comme jamais.
Un brin de toilette pour les uns.
Et dès que possible,
Pour toute la troupe,
Le repos du guerrier.
Il est à peine 19h30,
La plupart des soldats dorment déjà.
Presque tous ont l'estomac vide.
Un réveil à la lumière du jour.
Pierre et Sam s'activent.
Ils attendent d'une minute à l'autre,
L'arrivée des instructeurs pour une inspection générale.
Ils vont tout évaluer.
L'abri, le lit, le feu et le Katouri,
Un sac à dos de survie.
Pas simple à confectionner avec des feuilles de palmier.
Et il est difficile de se concentrer,
Quand les premiers effets de la faim se font sentir.
Dès que je me lève, j'ai la tête qui tourne.
Déjà, les voix, on les entend plus pareil.
Que ce soit Mika ou Pierre qui parle,
Je ne comprends pas leur voix.
Au niveau de l'ouïe, c'est hallucinant.
Ouais, c'est une première pour moi.
Sorti de nulle part,
Le sergent chef débarque au bivouac et le capitaine Samuel,
Vont tout passer au peigne fin.
Vous ne touchez plus rien.
Ce n'est pas la peine de rajouter des feuilles !
C'est trop tard !
Vous êtes sur votre position et vous ne bougez pas.
L'heure du verdict.
Pour les soldats,
La note d'aujourd'hui est capitale pour l'obtention du brevet final.
Donc la toiture, il n'y a pas assez d'épaisseur.
Là, l'eau coule ici, elle ruisselle sur les feuilles,
Ça coule et t'es mouillé.
Donc ce n'est pas bon là.
Les fourches sont trop petites.
Là, le plancher, je n'en parle même pas.
Tu n'as même pas la moitié,
Avec des petites perches qui ne sont pas maintenues.
Donc là, c'est pas bon !
Il est où ton feu ?
Le feu est éteint.
J'avais dit quoi hier ?
Le feu est allumé quand j'arrive.
Donc là, c'est pas bon.
Plus sévère encore dans son jugement,
Le sergent chef Thomas.
Solide.
C'est solide, ça ?
D'où vient cette technique de réalisation ? De Madagascar ?
Pour Emilio, comme pour les autres,
Rien n'échappe à l'instructeur.
Aucun défaut n'est toléré.
Ça, ce n'est pas la technique qu'on vous a montré.
Ça, c'est de la merde.
Katouri ?
Tu n'as pas trouvé de lianes dans la forêt équatoriale ?
Mais ce n'est pas bon, où sont les bretelles,
Les sangles de suspension ?
Ok, mets-le sur le dos.
Il n'y en a pas.
Sans bretelles, le sac est inutile.
Impossible de transporter quoi que ce soit dans la jungle.
Il manque les bretelles de suspension,
Il manque le fond du sac.
Une petite moyenne et encore.
La survie commence plutôt mal pour les militaires,
Et ça ne fait que commencer.
À 11h, ils sont rassemblés sur ordre du capitaine.
Donc là, deuxième jour de survie.
Là, vous êtes perdu, mais cette fois avec votre gilet.
Avant de démarrer cette nouvelle épreuve,
Le capitaine Samuel récompense les chasseurs de la veille.
Hier, le petit singe qui a été tué,
600 grammes, donc 600 grammes de riz.
600 grammes de riz aux chasseurs.
600 grammes, légèrement moins qu'espéré par Pierre et Sam.
Chacun pour sa gueule, apparemment !
Mais un bon repas en perspective tout de même pour eux deux,
Et eux deux seulement.
Aujourd'hui, la mission est de parcourir 6 kilomètres en pleine jungle.
Objectif,
Rejoindre leur nouveau camp.
Pour s'orienter, seule la boussole et une carte.
Le départ est donné.
Ils ont 3h pour rallier le nouveau campement.
Dans la forêt amazonienne,
Aucun point de repère pour s'orienter.
Le moindre écart de trajectoire,
Peut leur faire perdre de longues heures dans la forêt.
Pour éviter cette situation dangereuse,
Les stagiaires se concertent régulièrement sur le trajet à parcourir.
Et c'est le légionnaire junior,
Qui prend les choses en main.
Tout droit, tout droit !
Mais très vite, la tension est palpable.
Sam est en désaccord sur l'itinéraire emprunté.
Tiens toi à ce que tu as fait sur la carte.
Non, mais là, ça a changé.
Là, c'est 1420 millièmes.
On ne va pas se faire chier.
Si ça fait comme la rivière de tout à l'heure,
On ne va pas se faire chier et on s'est fait niquer.
Il n'y a personne qui s'est fait n****, Reste cool.
C'est 1600 pas jusqu'à la fin.
Vous me faites pas chier là,
Sinon, vous prenez Samuel et vous le faite.
C'est bon, on est bien là.
Vas-y, fais la topo,
Je suis maintenant.
Je sais que je bosserai avec des pros quand je rentrerai.
Pour corser l'affaire, les équipements sont lourds,
Les ventres sont vides et la chaleur est accablante.
Après 2h de marche,
Premiers malaises,
Le légionnaire Sergueï vient tout juste de rejoindre le stage.
Opérateur radio, il assure pendant la survie,
Une liaison de secours en cas d'urgence.
Sergueï est victime d'un coup de chaleur.
Il n'est pas le seul à souffrir.
À l'arrière. Mohamed n'avance plus,
Il ralentit la marche, ce qui énerve le groupe.
Quand vous avez mal, est-ce que je vous dis quelque chose ?
Tu veux qu'on appelle l'hélico ?
Bah avance alors !
Je fais des efforts pour avancer mais je ne peux plus.
J'ai pas compris.
Oui j'avance comme ça, mais...
Ferme ta g**** et avances !
Eh ben, tu avances comme ça, tu passes devant !
Il est où ton gilet ?
Avec les gars.
Depuis début, c'est un fardeau pour la section.
Il n'arrive pas à suivre, il n'arrive pas à suivre !
Mais faut qu'il arrive à la pirogue,
Et elle est pas ici !
Attends, quand il va arriver à la pirogue, il sera déjà mort.
Ah ba oui ça c'est sûr !
La fin de la marche est un calvaire pour le soldat Mohamed.
Arrivé à destination 1h plus tard, à bout de force,
Les pieds en feu,
Il est mis au pied du mur par les instructeurs.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Là, si je te ramène à la pirogue, c'est fini le stage !
Sachant que c'est loin d'être fini le stage !
L'autre pied c'est pire ou c'est mieux ?
Pire ?
Montre alors.
Parce que là, si vous n'êtes pas capable de marcher,
C'est 2 kilomètres pour rejoindre la pirogue encore.
Je vous embarque, mais je ne vous ramène pas.
Après la prochaine étape, c'est retour à Kourou.
Fin de stage, échec.
Mohamed craint le pire.
C'est le moment le plus redouté par les soldats.
La sentence que va prononcer le capitaine.
Tu mets tes rangers, tu viens avec nous à la pirogue.
Fini !
Qui veut arrêter encore ?
Qui a mal aux pieds ?
Le stage n'est pas fini !
Si vous n'avez pas de pied,
C'est pas la peine de continuer le stage !
Ça me fait mal au cœur !
Ça ne vaut pas le coup d'essayer quand même ?
Non, je ne peux pas.
Je ne peux pas marcher.
À seulement 5 jours de la fin,
L'aventure s'arrête pour le légionnaire Mohamed.
J'évacue un stagiaire qui ne peut plus marcher,
Il a les pieds complètement brûlés de mycoses.
Les soldats ne sont plus que 30 à rester en course.
Une marche que j'estime à 2h30, 3h grand maximum,
Ils viennent de la réaliser en 5h.
Donc il est hors de question que ce stagiaire,
Ralentisse les activités sur les jours à venir.
Donc je préfère tout de suite l'arrêter.
Il a les pieds ravagés par les mycoses.
Ça ne sert à rien de continuer,
Il sera incapable de poursuivre le stage dans des bonnes conditions.
Jusqu'au dernier jour,
Le stage de la Légion n'offre aucune chance aux maillons faibles.
Les soldats vont devoir à présent puiser dans leurs dernières ressources,
Pour continuer la partie survie.
À peine arrivés à leur nouveau campement,
Ils sont immédiatement à pied d'œuvre.
Leur nouvelle mission,
Construire des radeaux pour être capables de se déplacer sur le fleuve.
Première tâche,
Aller chercher du bois sur l'autre rive.
Allez, quelqu'un récupère.
Fais vite, ça pique !
Tout le monde s'active.
Le légionnaire Eliaquim s'occupe des lianes.
Comme les autres, il est affamé.
Ce n'est pas du tout facile.
Surtout quand on a le ventre qui n'est pas rempli,
Qui gargouille chaque minute.
Mais bon, on ne fait plus trop attention !
C'est comme ça !
Après, chaque fois qu'on trouve quelque chose,
On a envie de le manger.
Même la feuille devant moi, j'ai envie de la manger.
Mais bon, quand même, parfois, j'ai mes limites.
Même les plus endurcis, comme Nico,
Montre des signes de faiblesse.
C'est difficile !
J'ai la tête qui tourne, ça fait 3 jours qu'on ne mange pas !
Tous n'ont qu'une idée en tête,
Terminer au plus vite pour chasser et pêcher,
Avant la tombée de la nuit.
Sans la moindre énergie,
Ils ne sont plus que l'ombre d'eux-même.
Avec la faim,
Les esprits s'échauffent vite.
Chacun reprochant à l'autre de ne pas en faire assez.
Et alors ! Vous voulez vite manger ?
Vous voulez prendre une douche ou quoi ?
Il se repose ? Et nous on n'a pas travaillé jusqu'à maintenant ?
Laisse tomber p**** !
Moi je veux c**** et il faut que je me repose après aussi !
On est parti se faire **** à nager à contre courant.
Pour détendre l'atmosphère,
Sam préfère partir à la recherche de nourriture.
Avec Pierre, ils vont à la pêche aux crabes.
S'ils rentrent bredouilles,
Il n'y aura rien à manger au bivouac ce soir.
Ils sont chaud à avoir quand même !
Au moment où ils rentrent dans leurs trous.
Objectifs,
En rapporter suffisamment pour toute l'assemblée affamée,
Qui compte sur eux.
Voilà donc crabes des marécages.
Un petit goût salé.
J'aime bien.
C'est très goutu.
À la nuit tombée, de retour de chasse,
Pierre n'a pas encore eu le temps de faire goûter ses crabes.
Regarde en bas.
Il s'est blessé à l'œil.
L'infirmier Jérémy,
N'arrive pas à soulager sa douleur.
Je vois rien du tout, mais rien du tout.
Mais je ne peux pas le fermer.
Le problème, si c'est un truc qui est passé derrière,
Je ne peux pas l'enlever moi.
Au pire, je mettrai un truc comme ça,
Je laisserai l'oeil fermé et je finis le stage comme ça.
Je vais demander un avis médicale parce que...
Non on verra demain.
Pour Pierre, une seule crainte,
Ne pas pouvoir aller au bout de l'aventure.
Mon frère, deux fois, a chopé des copeaux de bois dans l'oeil.
Il n'y a qu'à l'hôpital qu'ils ont pu l'enlever.
Non, je ne vais pas à l'hôpital !
Je mets un cache et je finis mon stage.
T'es fou !
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Ouais je sais.
S'il faut que je finisse borgne,
Je finirai borgne mais je finirai quand même !
J'en ai rien à b****.
Et Dieu nous a donné deux yeux,
Je peux en n**** un !
Quand tu fermes ça te fais mal ?
Laisses ouvert, il va descendre.
Ça me fait chier de te faire un truc comme ça.
Ouais, mais je n'ai pas le choix mon gars.
Je trouve que c'est dégueulasse.
Tu sens une différence ou pas du tout ?
J'ai trop mal mon gars !
Un œil de merde !
J'en ai marre !
Je vais péter une pile !
Si je dois arrêter le stage,
Je me pète avec le chef, avec l'officier !
Calmes toi.
Ah non, il reste 6 jours gros !
Sam s'inquiète pour Pierre.
Son ami tiendra t-il le coup jusqu'à la fin ?
En attendant, au camp,
Les soldats peuvent enfin profiter du butin de Sam et Pierre.
Faute de mieux,
Les Crabes rencontrent leur petit succès.
Petite soupe de crabe,
Enfin de l'eau, des crabes et du sel !
On partage avec tout le monde.
Le repas a été frugal.
Alors pour oublier la faim,
Rien de mieux que de finir la soirée,
Avec un chant de la Légion.
Soudés autour du feu,
Il est maintenant temps pour les soldats,
D'aller se coucher.
Demain, malgré la faim et la fatigue,
Ils devront de nouveau répondre présent.
Il fait à peine jour quand commence la nouvelle épreuve.
Ce matin, les soldats doivent regagner le centre de la Légion,
Avec les radeaux de fortune qu'ils ont construits.
Ils seront une nouvelle fois chronométrés et évalués.
Allez les gars !
Première étape,
Mettre les radeaux à l'eau.
Ce qui provoque rapidement de nouvelles tensions.
Et toi ! Descends dans la boue.
Sinon, je monte ! Je vais vous jeter des galets sur la tête.
Je vous jure, j'en ai plein le c... !
C'est le moment de vérité.
Les radeaux vont-ils tenir le choc ?
Si ce n'est pas le cas, ce serait un échec pour l'ensemble du groupe.
La mise à l'eau est une nouvelle source de stress.
Comment tu me parle ?
Toi, je vais t'arranger tout à l'heure, tu vas voir !
Jusque là, pourtant, tout va bien.
Les radeaux ont l'air de flotter.
Maintenant, le plus dur reste à faire.
Coordonner la nage pour atteindre au plus vite le point d'arrivée.
Sur la ligne de départ, 3 équipes.
Les stagiaires ont 45 minutes,
Pour parcourir les 2 kilomètres,
Qui les séparent du centre d'entraînement.
Tout le monde est à cran, car l'évaluation et collective.
Tirez vers vous les gars !
Si on tire vers nous, on va se trouver dans la branche.
Tu comprends pas ?
Il a raison, il a raison !
Après 4 jours de survie, on voit qu'ils ont encore la patate.
Sauf qu'il y a un groupe qui a pris tout droit.
Et avec la marée qui descend,
C'est plus difficile de traverser.
Après 40 minutes,
C'est le groupe du caporal Pierre,
Qui atteint le centre d'entraînement en premier.
Les seconds, ralentis par le courant,
Ont finalement réussi le challenge,
À 10 minutes d'intervalle.
C'est physique, c'est physique !
Il y en a qui ne sont pas trop bon nageur dans le groupe.
Donc il faut toujours tirer ceux qui nagent pas trop bien.
Mais ensemble, on s'en sort toujours.
On a perdu une petite longueur au début par rapport au deuxième groupe,
Mais, énervés jusqu'au bout.
On a pas mangé, on est hargneux.
On a tout donné et on arrive les premiers.
Après quatre jours, la partie survie est terminée.
Et les gars, il y a de la soupe.
Les stagiaires vont enfin goûter à leur vrai premier repas.
Une soupe composée des restes de la cantine,
Du centre d'entraînement.
La colonne est derrière !
Pour les soldats affamés, un vrai menu 5 étoiles.
Ça a l'air délicieux,
J'ai l'impression que c'est le meilleure repas de ma vie !
Je n'ai jamais mangé une soupe aussi bonne,
Avec une telle envie.
Même ma mère n'a jamais aussi bien cuisiné de toute ma vie !
Franchement, c'est très bon.
La seule chose que j'attendais c'était ça !
Prendre un peu de force pour continuer les activités.
Parce qu'il reste encore 5 jours et il y a beaucoup de choses à faire.
20 litres de soupe,
Liquidés en moins de 10 minutes.
Le plein d'énergie pour la dernière ligne droite.
5 jours longs et éprouvants,
Qu'ils effectueront au sein du centre.
Quelques échauffements avant l'épreuve reine du stage,
La terrible piste Jaguar.
Vous avez 45 minutes pour le franchir.
Une dizaine d'obstacles, à première vue insurmontables.
Uniquement franchissable,
Grâce à l'esprit d'entraide et de cohésion du groupe.
Pas le choix, c'est une évaluation collective de nouveau.
Ça, c'est ma tête !
Chaque obstacle doit s'effectuer en un temps limite.
Pour le capitaine Samuel, l'affaire est mal engagée.
Là, on ne sait pas ce qu'ils ont fait.
Là, ils utilisent une seule sangle alors qu'ils en ont 4.
Aucun escalier n'a été construit.
On voit que les stagiaires, les derniers, n'arrivent pas passer.
Le chrono tourne.
Il ne reste plus que 5 minutes.
Un soldat doit encore franchir le mur.
Arranges ton Famas derrière le dos !
Au delà de la partie physique,
C'est la partie commandement qui nous intéresse.
Sa capacité à trouver les solutions pour franchir les obstacles,
Et surtout, les faire franchir, même au plus faible.
Tentatives de la dernière chance.
In extremis,
Le stagiaire passe l'obstacle,
L'épreuve est réussie.
Mais ce n'est qu'une mise en jambes.
Deuxième parcours,
Un passage sur des pieux humides et glissants.
Le groupe d'Emilio a exactement 20 minutes pour le franchir.
Les stagiaires, déséquilibrés par leur équipement,
Passent l'un après l'autre.
Pour l'instant, les hommes passent sans trop de difficulté.
Il n'en reste plus que 3.
Le chrono affiche 13 minutes,
Quand soudain...
Avec cette chute,
Le légionnaire met tout le groupe en difficulté,
Car il doit recommencer.
Maintenant, c'est au tour d'Eliaquim de se lancer.
Une chute douloureuse.
Mais pas le temps de s'apitoyer sur son sort.
Aller, il te reste 5 minutes pour passer là,
Sinon, c'est la pénalité pour le groupe.
À part Eliaquim,
Tout le groupe parvient à franchir l'obstacle.
Accroches toi bien avec ta musette !
La pression est sur lui.
Eliaquim n'a pas droit à un deuxième échec.
Si tu montes comme ça, tu vas être déséquilibré.
Fais ça bien et ne tombe pas.
Calme toi.
Doucement, doucement.
Attention enlevez-vous, je vais prendre mon élan !
À la toute dernière seconde,
Le groupe d'Emilio échappe à l'élimination.
C'était très difficile,
Parce que les poutres glissent,
Et en plus je suis tombé sur mes côtés et sur mes triceps antérieurs.
Je ne suis déjà pas très agile et à cause de cette chute,
Ça a diminué ma capacité.
Mais j'ai fait avec, j'ai serré les dents.
Et tu avais la pression de réussir ce deuxième passage ?
Oui j'avais la pression.
Mais ici, on serre les dents, on ferme le cerveau et c'est parti !
Consultation après.
Pendant ce temps,
L'équipe menée par le caporal Pierre est elle aussi en plein effort.
Sur les épaules des hommes,
Un tronc d'arbre de plus de 350 kg.
Seule manière de réussir,
Se relayer sans faire tomber le tronc.
De son côté, le groupe d'Emilio n'en a pas fini avec la boue.
Il aborde même la partie la plus redoutée de la piste Jaguar.
Le plan incliné.
À première vue, c'est infranchissable.
90 degrés, 90 degrés. Tu vois ?
Comme ça, ça ne glisse pas.
Avec les jambes en arrière, vous allez glisser.
Allez, avance là-bas.
Monte sur l'épaule.
Je t'ai dit de monter sur l'autre là !
Les soldats ont 20 minutes pour passer l'obstacle.
Et les règles sont très strictes.
Assis, assis là bas ! Personne, debout !
Un par un,
Au prix de tant d'efforts,
Les soldats viennent à bout de cette épreuve.
Mais la piste Jaguars leur réserve encore quelques surprises.
À venir,
Sur plus de 100 mètres,
Un parcours du combattant où les soldats doivent ramper,
Entre les barbelés.
Un véritable chemin de croix.
Chaque mouvement est un effort sans nom.
Enlisés dans la boue,
Les soldats progressent au ralenti.
30 minutes de calvaire pour venir à bout de la piste Jaguar.
Arrêtes de faire semblant !
En ligne !
Après l'épreuve,
Une douche façon légion.
Ok, là, c'est bon.
Récupérez votre matériel et rincez-le là bas.
Les mitraillettes et tout. Tout doit être propre !
Allez, c'est parti !
L'heure est à la récupération et au grand nettoyage.
Tout doit être parfait,
Les uniformes comme l'équipement.
Ça c'est notre temps de repos.
Il le faut car normalement demain ils vont contrôler l'armement.
Et s'il y a de la rouille ou autre chose qui ne va pas,
On va ramasser !
Pendant le temps libre, il faut contrôler le matériel et l'armement.
Chaque fois c'est pareil.
Tu entretiens ton arme, comme ton bien le plus précieux.
Pour quelques heures,
Les hommes ont enfin quartier libre.
Mais ça fait du bien de se reposer un peu,
Et surtout de se réapprovisionner en nourriture.
J'ai dû manger 4 rations depuis que je suis arrivé.
Ça va faire 2h qu'on est là,
J'ai déjà mangé 4 rations.
Après ces quelques instants de répit,
Les soldats entament l'ultime ligne droite du stage spécialiste forêt.
Pour leur dernier jour d'épreuves,
Ils sont acheminés par pirogue.
Ils vont naviguer pendant une dizaine de kilomètres.
Une fois débarqués,
Ils vont devoir rejoindre le centre d'entraînement,
Au pas de course.
Enlevez la veste !
Jusqu'à la dernière minute, les stagiaires vont en baver.
Et c'est l'instructeur Louis, qui est à la manœuvre.
Ok, on a environ entre 6 et 8 km.
C'est la fin de votre stage, ok ?
Alors on va arriver là-bas, ok ?
Chaque kilomètre c'est en moins, en un moins, en moins,
Pour finir le stage, ok ?
Alors on s'accroche tout le monde ! On s'accroche !
Le plus faible va devant, il maintient la cadence.
On reste tous groupés, ok ?
Est ce que c'est clair ?
Sac et Famas, ok ?
Un imprévu va rendre la course encore plus difficile.
Je l'ai laissé dans la pirogue !
Moi aussi.
Tout le monde enlève le chapeau.
On l'a tous ou on ne l'a pas !
Parce que 2 soldats ont oublié leur chapeau,
C'est comme ça, uniformité toujours !
La course se fera la tête découverte pour tout le monde.
Tous dans la même galère, à la Légion, on est solidaire.
Il fait 35 degrés.
Les hommes courent durant les heures les plus chaudes de la journée.
Louis donne la cadence et accompagne jusqu'au bout les légionnaires.
Si l'instructeur ne donne pas l'exemple,
On nous demande comment ?
Il faut toujours être au niveau,
Il faut toujours se préparer,
Il faut toujours être le meilleurs parmi nous.
Le groupe fait corps jusqu'au bout.
Nous on est à l'armée de la régulière, on pense à lui !
Pierre et Sam permettent à un légionnaire en difficulté de terminer la.
Pour le dernier kilomètre, à pleins poumons,
Les cris de la Légion.
Et en terminant avec cette course,
Ils en finissent aussi avec le stage.
Repos !
Un mois d'efforts, souvent surhumains.
Et à la clé, une victoire pour ses 30 hommes,
Qui ont tenu le choc.
Les gars, félicitations, c'est bien !
Voilà, apparemment, c'est fini.
Jusqu'aux réintégrations.
Ça c'est fait !
On a tout donné pour arriver jusqu'à la fin,
Pour nous mêmes.
Malgré la fatigue, la chaleur, je ne sais pas,
Je sens que demain c'est la liberté.
C'est ça le plus important !
Pour le reste, on s'en fou.
Rien dans la tête, tout dans le sac à dos.
Et c'est parti.
C'est le stage le plus dur que tu aies fait ?
Jusqu'à maintenant, oui.
Jusqu'à maintenant, oui,
C'était le plus difficile que j'ai fait.
La vérité.
Reste encore à connaître le classement,
Un dernier stress.
**** chaque fois j'ai mal !
C'est la même musique, c'est ça qui me **** !
Non mais si je cours, je vais vomir.
Arrêtez de rigoler !
La faim, la fatigue et les blessures paraissent déjà loin.
Avant même la proclamation des résultats,
De cette aventure de 4 semaines dans la jungle,
Les hommes ne retiennent plus que la réussite.
Ils l'ont fait,
Ils sont allés au bout d'eux mêmes et ils en sont très fiers.
Stagiaires et instructeurs pour une même fois,
Dans le même cadre.
À la nuit tombée, voilà le moment de vérité,
L'heure des résultats.
Les hommes font la queue devant le bureau du capitaine Samuel.
C'est maintenant au tour d'Emilio.
Caporal chef... À vos ordres mon Capitaine !
Je me mets au repos. À vos ordres mon Capitaine !
Tu n'es pas breveté.
Tu as raté la formation de bûcheron.
Tu as 7/20 en bûcheron et du coup cette qualification est éliminatoire.
Donc tu seras breveté aguerrissement.
Et je n'ai rien à reprocher sur l'état d'esprit.
Tu avais les chevilles enflées au bout de 8 jours,
Ça aurait pu te mettre en échec.
Tu as voulu continuer, tu as réussi à te rétablir,
Tu as été jusqu'à la fin du stage.
Par contre, tu repars non qualifié,
Pas breveté.
Tu comprends bien pourquoi ?
Oui mon Capitaine.
Est-ce que tu as des questions ?
Non mon capitaine.
Tu peux disposer.
Emilio est allé au bout du stage.
Je peux disposer. À vos ordres mon capitaine !
Mais son rêve de devenir instructeur forêt ne se réalisera jamais.
Même verdict pour Eliaquim.
Tu n'es pas breveté.
Tu t'y attendais ?
Oui mon capitaine.
Ok, tu es en échec également sur les deux parties Bûcheron.
Bûcheron, parce que le caporal chef t'as jugé trop dangereux,
Et navigation, parce que la pirogue ça ne va pas.
Je pense que tu n'es pas manuel.
Dans la vie, il y a 2 catégories de gens,
Les manuels et les intellectuels.
Donc toi, tu ne fais pas partie des manuels.
Ok, j'ai fait un compte rendu où j'explique,
Que tu étais peut être un peu jeune en service pour faire ce stage.
C'est un stage long, difficile.
T'as le mérite d'être allé au bout.
Parce que c'était un stage physique, c'est un stage rustique.
Et au départ, c'était pas gagné, je pense.
Moi, quand je t'ai vu arriver,
J'ai pensé que tu ne tiendrais pas une semaine,
Et pourtant tu avais tout le temps un bon état d'esprit,
Tu t'es accroché et tu as quand même le mérite d'être allé au bout.
Demain, tu seras breveté aguerrissement.
Un échec qui n'est pas vraiment une surprise pour lui.
Eliaquim est déjà fier d'avoir tenu jusqu'à la fin de l'aventure.
Sur les 30 rescapés,
24 soldats ont décroché le précieux brevet.
Parmi eux, les inséparables Pierre et Sam,
Tout sourire au moment des adieux avec le capitaine Samuel.
Direction Kourou,
La base du troisième régiment étranger d'infanterie.
Après 2h de route et de sommeil réparateur,
Arrivée au quartier général de la Légion, en Guyane.
Dans les chambrées, les soldats se mettent sur leur 31.
Uniformes impeccables.
Coupe réglementaire.
C'est beau !
Devant le miroir,
Les corps apparaissent marqués par l'intensité des efforts et les privations.
Moi, j'ai maigri de 10 kilos.
Avant le stage j'étais à 82kg,
Là, je suis à 72.
En tenue d'apparat, les légionnaires n'ont qu'une hâte,
Connaître leur classement.
Verdict dans quelques minutes,
Après la traditionnelle levée des couleurs.
Enfin, le grand patron arrive.
Il va découvrir qui sont les recrues les plus valeureuses.
Proclamation des résultats.
Classé premier avec une moyenne de 16,72.
Le grand gagnant, Le légionnaire brésilien, Junior.
Pas loin derrière,
Le Serbe, Nikolaï, qui termine troisième.
Pierre et Sam finissent quatrième et cinquième.
Duo de choc jusqu'au bout.
Bien, je félicite tous ceux qui ont réussi le stage.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez une connaissance approfondie,
De la forêt équatoriale.
Le stage vous donne un certain nombre de compétences.
Ceux qui n'ont pas réussi le stage,
Je sais qu'il y en a qui sont en échec.
Quoi qu'il en soit, rien n'est perdu.
Ce que vous avez appris, vous le savez.
Et même si vous avez échoué sur un stage propulsiste,
Tout ce que vous aurez appris à côté,
Vous serez capable de le mettre en œuvre,
Au profit de vos sections.
Fin de la cérémonie.
Direction le foyer pour un cocktail.
Emilio commence à relativiser son échec.
Même si je n'ai pas le brevet,
Je suis content d'avoir terminé.
C'était ma fierté. Je vous le dis depuis le début.
C'est ma fierté intérieure.
Comme j'ai raté dans beaucoup de domaines,
Je n'ai que l'aguerrissement,
Mais c'est mieux que rien du tout !
Je pars quand même la tête haute.
Du côté des brevetés, Pierre et Sam savourent.
On ne visait pas vraiment le classement.
Déjà, on est arrivé dans le top cinq.
Je pense que c'est déjà pas mal sur un stage comme ça.
On se contente de ce qu'on a, ça suffit.
Encore plus fort sur le podium,
Le Serbe Niko.
Oui, je suis content.
Je savais que j'avais réussi le stage.
Je ne savais pas que j'allais être troisième.
Je pensais être cinquième, sixième, je ne savais pas.
Mais là, je suis impressionné.
Troisième, ça va.
Enfin la délivrance.
Leurs familles ne sont qu'à quelques mètres.
Mais avant de les retrouver,
Dernier geste symbolique.
Déposer les armes.
Cavalier sur le front.
Je vous demanderai ici de signer.
C'est fini, c'est fini !
On va se remplir la panse !
Bien manger, bien dormir !
Après 4 semaines dans l'Enfer vert,
Pour Pierre les grandes retrouvailles.
Bien, c'était bien ?
Tu m'as manqué, c'est trop !
C'est chaud !
T'es tout maigre !
Qu'est-ce que je suis maigre, arrêtes de me dire ça !
Sam, lui aussi retrouve sa femme.
C'était long.
C'était trop long !
Je pue ?
Un petit peu !
Sinon toi, ça s'est bien passé ?
Comme quelqu'un qui a été seul pendant un mois et demi.
Alors heureuse ?
Vous pouvez même pas vous imaginer.
C'était très long, ça a été dur.
Mon mari m'a beaucoup manqué.
Et puis, je pense qu'on est toutes dans le même cas !
C'était super dur moralement.
Même pour moi, ça a été dur de le soutenir.
Donc voilà, il est bien amaigri.
Mais bon, il va bien bien se reposer la semaine prochaine.
On est tous les deux en vacances donc on va en profiter.
Ouais, ça m'a aidé de penser à Marine pendant ces 4 semaines.
Marine, ma fille, ma famille, tout ça, ça m'a bien aider !
Caroline, enchantée.
Ça aurait peut être aidé de se connaître.
Les femmes de Pierre et Sam viennent de faire connaissance.
Elles pourront dorénavant se soutenir,
Lors des prochaines missions de leur mari.
C'est déjà prévu, dès la semaine suivante.